Hey,
what's going on is bill burr and it's the Monday morning podcast for Monday.
Um,
September 21st,
2050.
What's going on?
How
well you do?
I just yelled at like,
you know,
like your mom would yell down the street Jaffrey calm.
They're fucking
that shit when you could play outside,
you know,
without adult supervision because people weren't afraid that there was a fucking
pedophile behind every God damn tree.
Remember that shit?
Your mom would come out,
we had like a dinner bell.
He knew.
And your 12 brothers and sisters would come running up to fucking driveway like
cattle.
Yeah.
You don't remember that shit?
You guys all just fucking,
you just the days started the day fucking started.
Right?
And your mother would just open the door,
like,
get the fuck Outta here.
Get Out.
That was like parenting back then during summer vacation.
They just opened the door and they let you outside.
They did the same thing with their dogs.
There was no leash law or anything.
You just had like neighborhood dogs.
They just fucking walked around and asked the same thing they did with kids.
They just open the door,
get out,
go outside and play,
come back at lunch.
Right.
You have to lunch,
you go back out again,
you know?
And that'd be all right.
Come back out.
Come back when the street lights come on,
come back,
you know when it gets dark or whatever.
Watch your little brother.
That was it.
I think parenting was a lot easier back in the day cause you were allowed to
just send your kids outside.
So having them standing in the backyard,
like those fucking llamas,
you ever see that shit?
You drive down the street and you see a fucking Lamoney.
There's so many goddamn lamas in this country.
I don't understand it.
They're not indigenous to this country and I don't know what,
how people are making money off of
you don't know.
You don't ever see that shit in the grocery store.
Do you?
You know Lamstar Lama steaks,
Miss shanks
showing that fucking guy in a,
with the shrimp boat in that fucking movie with Tom Hanks when he had this
George Stile in haircut Yoseph,
Yoseph stolid Forrest Gump.
Hmm.
I know.
What the fuck am I tell?
Yeah,
you can just fucking send your kids outside.
All right.
Get outside.
You fill them up with sugary cereal and you just set them outside and then you
went out,
shot.
You ran around and he just ran into other kids.
Then somebody had a book of matches and then you just let the woods on fire did
basically,
I mean,
I'm fast forwarding through most of my childhood experiences,
but that's basically what you did.
They just fucking let,
yeah,
we to say it's pretty cool to me.
Fewer a stay at home mother.
Right?
You got four fucking kids.
You go in and out of your mind.
You're going out of your mind,
right?
Your husband goes to work every day.
What's he do?
He's a milk man.
He's a postman.
He's jumped in that has a man at the end of it,
right?
Because jobs were for fucking men back then.
Right?
They added,
figured out,
hey,
sugar tits.
You stay.
You stay home with the kids.
Hey,
don't you back?
Talk me.
I have a penis.
You shut your face.
Quit your client.
Quit your crying in front of the kids.
You fucking stay off.
All right.
What are you crying about?
Did I buy you an oversize jar?
Fluffer nutter in the cabinet.
What are you going to do?
Huh?
Okay.
You got to grab some fucking white bread out of a bag.
You've got to take off the twisty tie.
That's a be a big party of fuck fucking day.
You're bitching of up.
Okay.
I got to deliver milk to everybody.
It's in fucking glass bottles.
Do you how much pressure that is,
right?
He just fucking leaves her at home.
He goes off to work.
He's a fucking Milkman or a postman is somehow we can that you can afford a
house visit.
Bankers were actually semi regulated back then.
Yeah.
The upper 1%.
The fucking loaded takes up there to fuck each other at these parties were an
owl.
Masks and and what and whatnot.
Something with horns on it.
Right?
Walking around wearing sheets.
MMM.
These fucking guys.
The middle class.
You could actually,
you could,
you could have a stay at home mother.
Stay at home wife.
Okay.
So you went off to work and your fucking truck and you silly little uniform
looking like a character actor on Alice,
right?
And then she fucking stayed hall.
What does she do?
Everybody gets up.
She's like,
Jesus Christ,
right?
She takes out a pack of fucking Paul Miles.
Some cools,
maybe some Marlboro's,
whatever the fuck she said.
Some Winston's the fuck.
What the fuck did women's smoked back then?
You know,
it's so funny.
There's so many comics out there that do jokes about what,
uh,
black people smoke pile miles and cools and all that.
That I don't even know why people will Marlboro's Winston Salem lights.
Is that what it was?
My parents never smoked.
I don't fucking know.
So whatever you'd take out a cigarette,
right?
So you got your bathrobe on,
you get,
you fucking wait all on one leg with your hand on the same hip,
right?
Steering yourself up a cup of Joe.
Oh,
you're a maniac.
Kids come down the stairs or up the stairs and maybe halfway up the stairs if
you looked,
and then they're on a landing at the front door.
If you lived in a split entry,
I don't fucking know.
Okay.
I remember I stood the split entry.
You know what I mean?
The split entry is the House version of you ever see those people that have like
really long torsos they have the torso of a six foot four person,
but the legs of a jockey.
You know what I mean?
That blue collar body,
I always tease rich Vos.
He's got that body long ass fucking torso on these little doll legs,
right?
Just that blue collar body you just built for picking up boxes.
You don't even have to bend over.
You just fucking your arms almost dragging on the fucking ground.
All the split entry.
That's the house version of that body.
So anyway,
she makes you a fucking fluffing other sandwich.
None ad that's the lunch.
I'm sorry.
She fucking pulls out.
What do you guys want?
You want Frankenberry cocoa bear chocolate berry.
No count.
Shocki love Frankenberry or booberry,
whatever the fuck he had.
It turned the melt,
the color of the goddamn cereal.
You ate that shit.
She let you watch a couple of cartoons.
She finishes off for fucking cigarette,
stomps it out and that fucking ass trade and that's it.
All right.
Go outside and play.
What the fuck does she do out there?
Kids are outside running around meeting other kids,
playing with matches,
right?
Stealing,
playboys.
Simple Shit.
There's no cell phones.
There's no iPad.
There's no fucking overhead.
Okay.
What did you have to buy your kid for toys back then,
then there was nothing.
Tonka truck where that set you back?
Talk a truck and a book of matches.
I mean you were set for the fucking summer.
So anyway,
I don't want to fuck up talking to him and get on the stick.
Yeah.
Oh cause I screamed the podcast like a mother yelling and that's right down the
fucking street.
You know,
nowadays you got to sit there and you got to watch these little fuckers.
24 seven make sure they don't bump into anything.
They all have cell phones.
You know what I mean?
Like they're working on Wall Street.
You know,
I don't fucking know.
Who knows?
They'll probably,
they'll stop microchip and I'm soon.
Do you know,
somebody sent me an article about this,
uh,
this healthcare provider somewhere over in Europe that was giving out this band
that had a microchip in it and it tracked everybody that was in,
they were testing it out to track people that were insured by this health care
provider.
And it basically tracks your activity throughout the day,
you know,
and if you would just sitting around like a lump of shit,
they were like,
all right,
this fucker's going to have a heart attack.
We're raising his rates and um,
it's totally that George Orwell,
uh,
is it Orwell?
What do you make the popcorn now?
That was Orville Redenbacher.
I don't fucking know that Orwellian,
how many is that hacky think slippery slope into the Orwellian something or
other.
Right.
And um,
they were saying that they tried this fucking basically microchipping people
out.
Microchipping people out tested,
tested,
trying the micro chipping people.
Right.
And that they said they had an overwhelmingly positive response to it.
Well,
of course she did.
Of course you did.
Because most normal people would be like,
you want to do what?
Go Fuck Yourself.
That's creepy.
I don't want you to do it and then guess what?
They're not in the study.
Then what do you do?
You find some fucking jerk offs that don't have two nickels to rub together and
you say,
listen,
we'll get you a fucking ham sandwich with some cheese on it and what do you,
whatever kind of chips you want with it.
If you wear this fucking bracelet like all you gotta do is where the Brad saw
you've got to do this stupid and in the end they get a sandwich out of it.
Of course you're going to say they enjoyed it.
This is the thing about getting microchipped in the future.
It's inevitable that it's going to happen because isn't as much as people are
going to fight.
It is many people that fight it and don't want it there.
You cannot.
You cannot overcome the sea of mouth.
Breathe in fucking buffalo wild wings,
fucking morons that are out there.
There's way too many of them and they will walk towards the light every fucking
time.
All they got to do is flip on the switch or whatever direction they want to hurt
to go in.
And they just start walking towards it.
Ah,
they just start walking towards it.
They don't give a fuck.
And this is the greatest thing about all of it.
If you're one of the people running shit right,
is the mouth breathing morons opinion is held with the same level of,
uh,
of importance as somebody who actually a intelligent or informed,
you know what I mean?
The guy who sits at God though,
why do I give a fuck if they know whether or not I had a slurpee and not eight
or not?
That's just as much fucking right and just as much say as someone,
excuse me,
who's,
who's fucking informed,
you know,
that's when they take the constitution seriously.
And then everybody has rights.
That's when the upper 1% listen to it and they go,
hey,
wait a minute.
Don't be an elitist.
Right?
But then when it comes to the other shit,
when it's advantageous on the other,
right,
then,
then all of a sudden not on out where you know,
you don't have as much say as I do.
Right.
You know,
it was on a plane.
Right.
I'm in Austin,
Texas right now getting ready to do two wonderful shows here in this,
this bat infested toe.
Um,
okay.
They,
uh,
somebody had left in the pocket,
in the seat in front of me right seat,
but whatever the seat pocket in front of me.
This book on.
Yeah.
A,
that was just dedicated to yachting.
Okay.
And uh,
I got to tell you,
it was one of the most fascinating fucking magazines I've ever read read in my
life.
I don't know shit about the,
see,
I don't know shit about boats,
but just looking at this magazine,
knowing that,
that there's like people that read that magazine getting to be like,
yeah,
you know what?
I'm going to buy that yet.
So when the yacht world,
what I learned.
Yeah.
Okay.
And this is someone who doesn't know the difference between Port and starboard.
I'm going to guess port his right hand.
No,
left left is port right?
A starboard.
Okay,
because you read left to right,
but they always make right above left in a religious way.
Right.
He sat on the right hand of the father to go either way.
Plows up front,
starts in the back port and starboard.
I had a fucking though,
I think ports left.
Sounds really quick.
Port left devil right.
Fuck you.
You don't current star board.
Oh,
that's what we all are.
Um,
anyways,
we plow ahead.
Hit the whole fucking thing was about the size of your God damn boat.
Okay.
Who's got the biggest fucking boat and how big can these boats get?
So right now,
the biggest one out there,
I've already forget the name of it.
And that's another thing too.
The names of the boat,
uh,
just as entertaining is trying to understand how somebody has $300 million for a
fucking boat.
It does it immediately get out of it.
It's a fucking boat that is just an absolute money pit.
The second shoe by that fucking thing,
there's nothing you can do with that boat.
To him,
I guess you could rent it out,
you know,
to Jay z and Beyonce,
God knows they're always out on a fucking boat,
right?
Dressed in all white linens.
How could you make fucking money off of that?
This thing was like the biggest one they had was almost 600 fucking feet.
And what I learned is that basically a yard cost a million a meter.
Now we're going from standard to metric,
and I've just completely fucked myself here.
But as far as I know,
okay,
that
okay
fucking boat.
Yeah.
But basically it costs like what?
What's Seinfeld made when the entire series went into syndication,
all of that money,
half a billion dollars for a fucking boat.
And then you got to have like a and see me like a hundred people just to run it.
That's the funniest shit.
So even when you're on it,
like,
honey,
let's just take the boat out.
Just you and us,
you know,
let's reconnect.
Just you and us.
You,
Anna sent a hundred other fucking people,
right?
It's like you're doing an episode of the love boat,
but nobody else showed up except for the fucking,
the whole crew.
It's got to be weird.
No one,
they're all listening to you fucking right.
Some guy,
you know,
200 fucking yards away,
wherever the fuck he is with a big dumb tall hat making you a sandwich.
It's got all this extra food just for you and your wife.
Um,
anyways,
I was reading that and I was just like,
how the fuck could anybody legally make enough money?
And I was trying to think of the ways,
well,
you could start Facebook.
Even then,
that dude from Facebook,
what is he worth?
Let's say he's worth $3 billion.
Are you going to blow half a billion on a boat?
That's still a sizable chunk of your fucking fortune.
Okay.
You know,
it was the coolest part of the magazine was on the front.
Like,
you know,
it was somebody's personal magazine obviously.
And there was where like the address was supposed to be,
it was,
was taken away,
was torn off.
And I was like,
well,
I was wondering like where they lived,
you know,
six,
Illuminati court,
Connecticut,
someplace in Connecticut.
I always feel like the Illuminati lives in Connecticut.
All right.
And then I like helicopter into Manhattan,
Blah Blah,
blah,
blah.
No,
it doesn't make any noise.
They got some stealth helicopter.
So I'm really going off the fucking rails here on it.
So you've got to be asking yourself,
well built,
well,
you know,
you sit in there crying poor house.
Why the fuck are you sitting in the section of the plane that uh,
has yachting magazines left behind?
You know why?
Cause I did 23 years on the fucking road and I got miles bay,
I got status,
I got status.
Fuck you.
I flew in the back of the plane for 20 fucking years with you.
God Damn animals.
Okay.
And I get the fucked up left knee to prove it.
I'm never sitting back there again with you animals.
I swear to God I'm never doing it again.
You know why?
Cause I think I'm too cold.
I'm too good for you.
Anyways,
let's get to the,
uh,
let's do some reads here.
Now I got to fucking type in my God damn password.
Okay.
Uh,
the fuck I hate.
I,
you got to have some capitals in that till you know,
cause then what,
you know,
then it takes for fucking ever and ever and ever.
And then he'd say,
well how the fuck is that?
Every time I go to type in my password is fucking wrong.
Okay.
Nope.
And I left it on the capital's this how long it takes for you,
type them.
I'm still trying to do it and now I'm sitting in,
see,
this is how fucking dumb I am.
And I sit at the front of the plaintiff.
No,
that should give you hope.
Did I do it right now?
Wait a second.
All right.
Capital.
No capital.
That'd be go no capital.
Come on bill.
Come on.
Give me a winner.
Gimme a winner and hit it.
Yeah.
All right,
let's do some advertising here.
Sorry about that.
Um,
all right,
everybody,
dollar shave club.
Everyone stopped shaving with an old ray.
So it's gross.
It's disgusting.
You're better than that.
All right.
Why are you torturing yourself with the gross old blade every week after week,
Huh?
What's wrong with you?
Don't you love yourself or it's probably because you don't want to shell out 20
bucks for a pack of new ones,
do you?
Your face isn't worth 20 bucks.
Well,
you know what?
The people at Dollar Shave Club had revolutionized the way men shave.
Okay.
You're too cheap to save your face.
Well,
here's dollar Shave Club does save the day with dollar shave club.
You can shave with a fresh blade.
Oh,
it smells delicious as often as you want,
because they deliver a whole sleeve of amazing race is just for a few bucks a
month,
a whole sleeve.
Everybody just like that sleeve Oreos he ate last night except their razors.
The razors are so good.
Millions of guys have joined.
I think it's because it's so cheap personally.
Even the billion dollar razor corporations are freaking out,
but instead of lowering their bloated prices,
they're trying to fool you into milking the same blade for an entire month and
that's gross.
They've price gouged us for long enough.
Never go back to squeezing weeks and weeks of Shave shaves out of disgusting,
rusty out of a disgusting rusty blade.
Joined Dollar Shave club and use a fresh blade whenever you want.
Jesus,
he's words at difficult for me.
It feels amazing and it's a third of the price.
Join the millions of others who figured out this smarter way to shave.
Join Dollar Shave club now by going to dollar shave club.com/burr that's dollar
shave club.com/bar hey dollar shave club.com/bar all right,
legal zoom,
everyone.
You know what?
You shouldn't have to choose a random lawyer who charges expensive hourly rates
when you need legal help,
but the legal system is so complicated.
What other choice do you have when you need help with your business or want to
protect your family?
Well,
you can start with legal zoom.
I feel like I should be sitting on the front of a desk as I say this in some
office with a bunch of books behind me and right at this point is the part where
I stand up.
You know,
they make it easy for more than a decade.
For more than a decade.
They've provided a way for regular people like you would me regular down to
earth.
People like you and me.
Hey,
you can relate to me,
the speaker here to confidently navigate the legal system.
Legal Zooms,
not a law firm.
And that's how they,
that's how they provide such great value.
It's not a lot for him.
Then why do you call yourself legal zoom?
Yeah.
Hey,
Eddie apple cart.
We don't sell apples.
Uh,
they don't on charging you by the hour.
Instead you'll get a transparent pricing and customer reviews so you know
exactly what you're getting up front if you need help for with co in
corporations,
LLCs,
trademarks,
last wills,
living trusts in more legalisms the smart choice.
They got the right people on Andy,
answer your goddamn questions.
If you need legal help,
their network of independent attorneys can provide the straight forward guidance
you need in most states and other states just screwed.
But most states you're going to be fine.
Don't let legal hurdles become an excuse.
Go to legalzoom.com today to start building your own future,
the right way to save even more and a bar in the referral box at checkout.
That's legalzoom.com promo code bar high legalzoom.com Promo Code Berg.
Lastly,
but certainly not leastly
stamps.com your to do lists can seem out of control,
so much to do but so little time.
But here's one thing you can do that you can check off your to do list going to
the post office.
Thanks to stamps dot carb Carb,
carb,
carb was stabbed.
Start Carb Cook,
buy and print official US postage right from your own computer or brighter
stamps.com we'll send you a digital scale.
Automatically calculates the exact postage you need for any letter or package
and any class a male,
you'll never waste valuable time going to the post office again,
do everything right from your stay afraid from your desk with stamps.com print
the postage you need to put in your letter or package.
Then just handle it tended to your mail carrier and you're done.
I use stamps.com whenever I'm selling posters.
You know,
pouring myself out after the shows,
standing there next to sweaty drunk people who are taller than me with armpit
sweat that they stick on my shoulder right now.
Use My last name.
Birth for this special offer,
four week trial plus $110 bonus offer that includes a digital scale and up to
$55 free postage.
Don't wait.
Go to stamps.com before you do anything else,
can you click on the
microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinburgerthatstampsdotcomenterburpstamps.com
enter burr.
Excuse me,
sir.
Yes.
You stamps.com enter [inaudible].
All right.
That was those sort of painless when you think he closed this.
No,
I don't want to save that.
I don't want to save that at all.
All right,
so let's get back to the podcast here.
Uh,
let's talk football up,
up,
uh,
Bodo Gudu Gudu
Gudu.
Gudu Gudu too.
Um,
what a satisfying weekend that was for me as a football fan.
Everybody,
first of all,
Saturday night I went to a,
went to a wonderful
wedding and a afterwards we went to the after party.
We were in no fucking sports bar and um,
okay.
And we,
it was in,
we were on the island of Nantucket and uh,
I got to watch from the third quarter on,
I got to watch Mississippi,
all miss a beat.
Alabama,
the dre events tonight.
I got to watch them beat them men and I don't know why it is so much fucking fun
to watch Alabama lose.
Like I've said,
I don't hate them.
I actually liked Nick Saban,
but there's something about them you don't have.
It's just like how everybody hates the Patriots.
I get it.
We've won too much.
We're fucking annoying.
You know,
I actually met somebody that was,
you know,
we were talking about all that,
that patriots cheating shit and he brought up some other fucking great ones.
Evidently there's,
there's pictures of Jerry Jones,
the owner of the fucking Dallas cowboys getting off a party,
bucks hammered with like the head guy of all officiating in the NFL.
And I just laughed thinking if there was a picture of Robert Kraft doing that,
how long that fucking story would last.
Um,
that and that time the cowboys got caught with a,
for collusion with the Redskins to keep their free agents signings down so they
could feel better teams.
I mean,
it just,
you know,
that's fine.
That's not cheating.
It's all good.
It's just the Patriots.
Um,
anyways,
uh,
so I got to watch them lose what a fucking gay man and
okay.
The pictures of the fuck at Alabama fans when they would cut to the crowd,
when they were starting to sense that they were going to lose.
Like you just have to respect how much it makes the look at devastates.
You see the kid who's just fucking a dude who was just bent over at the fucking
wall.
I thought he was dead.
It just,
I watched that shit and I just fucking,
that's why I love sports because it's so fucking stupid that we give a shit to
that God damn level,
uh,
yet we do.
And,
um,
I love watching SCC football because,
uh,
I don't know.
There's a level of passion of the fans.
And I know I break the Alabama fans balls.
I don't give a fuck if you win another championship.
I actually Kinda one way want to see,
save and do it.
And when the most just to see,
just so I can say that I watched the,
uh,
the greatest college coach of all time.
But in the meantime,
every time you play,
I can't root for you.
If I look,
if I was born in Alabama,
you know,
and,
and crimson tide country and I was raised a fucking Alabama fan and I went to
that brutal period after bear Bryant left and that program went into the shitter
and I suffered through all those years,
then I can be excited about them being good again.
But I can't come from a pro sports fucking town and just jump on the bandwagon.
But what I can do is fucking root for the underdog,
which I did.
So congratulations to ole miss.
Um,
I can't imagine how fucking crazy you guys went to celebrating in Mississippi.
I open,
didn't gradually turned into a fucking race riot.
And you guys just,
you know,
wanting to start the fucking civil war again.
Uh,
hopefully you kept a tame,
you know what I mean?
Just tipped over a couple of cars and burned down some old trees or whatever the
fuck he do down there.
Uh,
but I got to watch that and uh,
I was actually traveling to Austin and I got to watch the first quarter of the
Patriots game and um,
you know,
it was just,
it was just fucking great just watching,
you know,
we're going to be the loudest fans and then having nothing to cheer about
because all of a sudden it's 21,
seven patriots after the bills just walked down the fucking field.
Totally fucking enjoyed that.
Um,
and once again,
this has nothing to do with bills fans.
It just has to do with the fact that the amount of shit that bill Bellacheck
gets for having no personality.
You know,
like these fucking sports journalists don't know exactly what Bella checks
doing.
They know that he's figured them out,
they know it,
and he's not going to let him in.
He's not giving him any billboard,
bulletin board material,
I should say.
And uh,
Rex Ryan,
they always be,
oh,
you know this guy,
you know,
he's not afraid to say what's on his mind.
That's how they paid him.
They just egg him on to keep saying dumb things.
Okay.
You know what I mean?
I don't,
for the life of me,
I don't know why rex Ryan talks the level of shit that he does,
but I'm so happy that he does it.
I'm so happy that he does it.
It's just like,
there you go.
Wrecks,
they go piss off Tom Brady.
See how that works for you.
Okay.
How does almost 500 yards passing,
how does that feel?
The sporting their rex keep talking shit.
Yeah.
You know what it is I really feel is because his level of insecurity outweighs
actually even winning the game that he has to shout down his own fucking demons.
Um,
having said that,
you know,
as much as I give wreck ship,
I know he's a great coach.
Uh,
I can't say great.
He hasn't won a Superbowl,
so he's,
he's a,
he's a really good coach.
And,
um,
yeah,
and he does it.
He has a great defense and I,
well,
you know,
they're gonna make their adjustments.
I think actually next game will actually be even closer obviously.
Um,
it's Kinda weird like his shit,
his shit talking made that a close game because the patriots,
rather than just handing the ball off and running out the fucking clock,
we kept throwing the fucking ball because it wasn't enough to beat them by 21
fucking points.
We wanted to beat him by 28 to 35.
Um,
so actually is shit-talking we feel looked at the end of the game,
the fact that,
you know,
okay,
yeah,
the game wasn't that fucking clothes.
You know,
that it was fun.
We only won by eight.
We kicked the shit out of him and then dopes,
we kept throwing the fucking ball,
um,
putting us in a position to give it right back to them,
which we did.
Um,
and then you go into the prevent and then all of a sudden this fucking inept
quarterback who throws the ball fucking 90 feet over everybody's fucking head
all day long.
All of a sudden looks like Joe Montana.
So,
um,
I dunno,
I'm psyched that that happened.
And um,
you know,
I hope,
when the Patriots go to play him again,
I hope rex talks a bunch more shit,
which,
you know,
we will,
which we'll get to patriots even more motivated to beat them.
I just don't understand it.
And these stupid fucking,
if you really listen to that guy,
he's not saying anything.
The players on his team,
they're not saying anything.
It's the just stating the obvious,
you know,
we're not afraid.
Okay.
They're not going to just step off the bus bus and we're going to give him the
win.
You know,
we,
we're,
we're coming out there to compete.
Oh,
are you?
Did you not compete?
Let did last week.
You didn't try.
It's a fucking NFL.
He should be doing that every fucking week.
Does Steel Kevin Mchale's great quote.
Way Back in the day when he played for the Celtics,
I remember,
you know,
they would some playoff series and they kicked the shit out of the other team
the first game.
Then some yell,
it team starts talking,
shit going,
you know,
we're not fucking around.
They'd better be ready because next game were common were coming and Kevin
Mchale cause you should be doing that every night.
This is the NBA fucking hilarious.
Hm.
Anyways,
so there you go.
Keep talking shit.
Everybody out there and a buffalo fence.
Mike adults.
You know what I mean?
I know rex is a very charismatic guy and you fucking,
you wanted to believe him.
Do you want it to believe him?
I know,
I know you did.
You know what's great about the Patriots winning is now I don't have to hear
from shred and Reagan out there in buffalo and I hope somebody sent you this,
this,
this fucking clip there fellas.
How you guys doing?
How many times did you guys almost fucking set up a phone call with me?
Shredding Reagan?
Two of my favorite people in,
they'll end the radio biz here.
You know,
as I travel the country,
these fucking guys are always,
they only call me when Buffalo Beats,
you know?
Okay,
what do you got?
You got to sabers and the bills,
you don't get a lot out there.
If they beat the Bruins and like a playoff series,
which I came in when that fucking happened.
Or if the PA,
the PA,
the bills would be this like twice.
I remember when we drew Bledsoe,
went to the bills and they won that bet,
that home game,
when they beat the crap out of us,
I got up,
I got a phone call then and then there was one other time.
It's hilarious and all they do is just talk about what a piece of shit bill
Belicheck is and all that and I just laugh at them.
So I got to think after that drive when you
went 80 yards,
went right down the field.
Yeah,
your,
your index finger was,
was quivering.
We've got to call up,
we got to call them.
Hit Sand.
Hit said,
wait a minute,
wait a minute.
Patriots.
Go right down the field.
Give you all the old right there,
Fred three and out.
Go right back down the field.
Another right there.
Fred right
now,
the three and out for you guys or a pick whatever the hell it was.
Malcolm Butler is amazing interception.
Malcolm Butler.
Right.
She's fucking wonderful.
So,
uh,
anyways,
I got to tell you,
you got to put Matt Cassel.
You know what I mean?
Matt Cassel did great with us when he was managing the Patriots.
Well Tom Brady was out,
right?
So I,
I still don't think that,
you know,
if we go and play the bills again,
that we definitely win the game because they got mad castle.
I still think a,
and I know that rex is a good enough coach if he has,
if he has a good defense,
but I think the great thing is going to be if he just keep,
just keep talking shit.
Rex,
keep talking shit.
You know dumb it is to talk shit on in a professional sports league.
Yeah.
Okay.
You know what I mean?
Like you're actually intimidating.
Somebody else says,
as a professionals,
they're not afraid of you and your nutrisystem wrecks.
They don't give a fuck.
Oh,
you're going to blitz.
All right,
so whatever.
So I got to watch that Shit and that was very enjoyable for me.
Um,
okay.
Yeah.
And it was wonderful.
I got a bunch of tweets from fucking buffalo fans taking on the personality of
their head coach and just watch to watch them slowly drop off after that opening
drive.
You know,
it's so funny.
And then to watch him slowly come back as we almost fucked up the end of the
game and then it just watch him disappear again.
It was really enjoyable.
You know,
it's like when I was in Nantucket hearing the surf,
that's all it is.
That beginning sound is bills fans before the game that ends sound is them at
the end.
So anyways,
uh,
oh,
freckles has got to get back on the wagon.
So I,
um,
I'm totally off my diet.
I drank like a fish last week,
like a maniac to the point yesterday when I was walking through the airport,
I had like heartburn and everything like that because I stuffed that I had not
eaten in the entire time.
I was,
uh,
you know,
dieting tiny,
lose the weight.
I was drinking beers,
I was smoking cigars,
I was eating chips,
ice cream,
the whole wedding cake,
the whole fuck.
I just chowed.
And um,
so yesterday was,
was the big day.
Well,
yesterday I was like,
uh,
you know,
I'm gonna be
traveling all day in airports,
so you know,
I'm not going to eat healthy.
So I just was like,
all right,
well let's,
let's,
we got a three headed monster here.
We get sugar,
salt and boost going on right now.
Let's chop one head off.
So I was just like,
all right,
no booze today.
So,
um,
and I've,
I'm,
I'm doing this run at dates through Texas,
so there's some friends coming out tonight.
So tonight I'm going to have a couple of drinks.
The rest of the week I'm having none.
And then in Toronto I have some friends up there and I'll probably have a couple
of drinks,
but the second that is over,
I am back on the wagon again,
um,
for at least until mid October,
if not until the night of the Madison Square Garden Show,
depending on how I feel.
Um,
I actually think this is what I'm gonna do.
I'm gonna go after this.
This thing is over.
I'm drinking two times on this trip.
Then I'm back on the wagon except for on October 17th,
um,
back on the wagon until Madison Square Garden.
That's how it's going down.
October 17th.
Why,
why are you going to drink that day?
Because I'm going to,
uh,
Papa,
Papa.
I'm going to fucking a Notre Dame USC.
I'm starting to run a dates through the Midwest to get ready for the Madison
Square Garden show and a,
why not start it off at arguably the most legendary football program in the
country,
right?
The Notre Dame fighting Irish.
So legendary.
They've been on national television,
even though they've sucked every fucking weekend for the last 15 years.
They've been on the,
on the,
on the tube.
So I'm going to that game.
So,
um,
and when I get,
I'm going to try to eat as well as I can on this tour and when I get back,
I'm going right back to that psycho fucking died because,
uh,
it took me too,
God damn long.
It's too much bullshit to lose all this fucking weight that I don't want to go
back.
So,
uh,
and I,
you know what's helping me is to actually tell you guys that I'm doing it
because if I don't tell you,
if I just do this in my head,
then I can slack off.
There's nobody give you to give me shit.
But if I tell you guys and I'm going to do it,
then you guys could turn the tables on me and be like,
hey bill,
we just checking on
to see how you're doing them.
Um,
all right.
So anyways,
when I was,
um,
here's another thing I'm done with fish.
I'm not eating fish,
uh,
any more because,
okay.
Because there's none left is basically what I learned because I've been going to
Nantucket and I've gone out and gone fishing every single time and every single
time I've gone it's been harder and harder and we've have to throw the lines
deeper and deeper to try to get fish.
And this just fucking nothing left.
And I was talking to this guy and he was talking about what are all these
fishing areas up in New England that people thought would never be fished out.
He said a completely fished out.
And uh,
that's something I wish they would just say,
um,
you know,
in this presidential election that they would be like,
hey,
why doesn't everybody just lay off fish,
go real easy on the fish for like the next fucking decade?
Let's just let him come back.
There's nothing wrong with eating fish,
but there's too many fucking people.
Let's just fucking lay off it.
We can make cows and chickens,
we can force him to fuck each other,
you know,
and we can eat those and lamb and all of that shit.
But like the fish,
you know,
what are we doing here?
You just let them come back.
Like I got to tell you,
like once we just kept pulling a blues,
I guess,
which don't taste good,
so we'd throw him back.
I really did not enjoy it when I think about it.
And,
uh,
then we ended up pulling up these fluke,
who the fuck eats fluke?
We just doing it to pad our fucking stats and then brought it in.
I felt we got took way too much fish than we were actually going to eat.
Um,
just so you could have the fun of fishing.
It's just,
there's always that thing.
Anytime I've gone fishing that I always feel like there's that tipping point
where it's like,
all right,
we've caught our dinner and now we're just killing shit just to kill Shit.
And uh,
I always feel like,
like a fucking chimpanzee then.
You know what I mean?
I feel like,
you know,
acting like a bunch of apes,
if you watch,
I fucking hate chimpanzees,
I can't fucking stand.
And when did they,
when they do a real documentary on him,
I see so much fucking sadistic human behavior in him.
Uh,
the way,
you know,
when they go out and they kill them,
another monkey,
you know,
I watched one one time just standing on the thing's fucking back,
just digging into what's back,
pulling out flesh.
It could have just killed it,
but it was actually getting off on here.
And the other thing screaming.
And I just so much fucking sadistic human behavior in it.
I fucking,
I hate him.
And I just felt like when we were still pulling the fish out just to be doing
it,
I felt like we were a bunch of chimps.
Like we should've been doing that,
you know,
walking around that weird chip walk fucking punch in our chest.
You know,
maybe I'm over fucking reacting,
but uh,
I gotta tell you my favorite part of,
um,
of the fishing trip
other than watching one of the guys I was with polling this beautiful bass
fucking gorgeous fish that I knew we were going to cook up and eat and they
would feed all of us.
Um,
was when,
uh,
there was a school of porpoises,
there was,
when I was swimming along the boat,
I actually took video,
you know,
something.
I don't know how to do it.
I'll give it to my guy.
Maybe he'll be able to upload it correctly.
But that was the best part of it.
Um,
personally was fucking amazing,
man.
And watching those things,
cutting through the water,
like a Goddamn sports car.
That was the best part.
But killing the fluke.
I just felt we've taken up the fluke man,
those stupid flat fish.
I just felt like I was beaten up a three year old.
Um,
so anyways,
let's,
uh,
yeah,
it's fucking a,
let's do some of the reeds here for this week.
Um,
oh,
hey,
by the way,
if you want to send in a,
um,
a,
a question here to the podcast,
the,
what you send it is to bill at the Mlm,
podcast.com.
And that's all lowercase except for the m's in Mlm podcast bill at the MLM
podcast.
Um,
oh,
did anybody watch the Emmy's last night?
Um,
I didn't watch them.
I was traveling and,
um,
evidently somebody gave some powerful speech.
Some woman gave a speech about a racism and all that.
And of course the crowd went fucking crazy.
And,
uh,
I,
I don't fucking get that moment when somebody black is on stage.
Right?
And they talk about how racist Hollywood is and how it needs to stop the level,
like the white people in the crowd,
almost like trip over themselves to stand up and applaud.
And it always comes off so fucking phony to me,
like the level that,
the level that they're screaming and applauding and crying and doing all this
fucking bullshit.
It's just like you guys are the guys who were running the shit.
I'm not talking about the actors,
but this leg show runners in the crowd.
There's this heads of studios and all that.
It's like if you really gave a fuck to the level that you're acting like you're
given a fuck,
the person on stage wouldn't have to be making,
wouldn't have to be making this speech.
I think it's so fucking,
I think that they did jumping up and they're applauding at that fucking level
because they don't want to get caught on camera,
not collapse.
You know what I mean?
I'm not saying that all white people a bet.
All right.
I'm not saying that shit,
but it at it just,
I don't,
I don't fucking get that moment.
I feel like whiteys like me in that moment rather than applauding wildly should
be gone.
Like,
Aye.
You got us.
Your eye,
your eye.
We've got it.
We got to work federal.
We've got to work harder on that one.
Sorry.
Sorry about that.
Instead of standing there applauding as if you're not part of the problem.
You know what I mean?
It's even myself.
As much as I feel like things should be fair,
I don't do anything about it.
You know what I mean?
I'm just trying to keep my boat afloat.
Right.
Okay.
That's actually kind of funny when you think about it,
when you think about how cutthroat show business is,
the most honest things that white people could do in that point at that point
would not be to applaud.
There'll be like,
wait a minute.
This business is hard enough for us.
Where with it being completely unfair and tilted in our favor,
why?
I applaud to level it out like,
yeah,
make it harder for me.
Hello fucking balding,
redhead and male.
I needed to be slanted in my favor as much as possible.
That would be the most honest moment.
Okay.
The most honest reaction,
but everybody doesn't.
They all stand up and freak out and this is what it really pisses me off is they
then think that yeah,
I'm a good person cause I just did that.
This person is going through this shit.
They said they're sick second going through this shit and I'm going to stand up
and applaud and be like,
that's right.
You shouldn't have to go through that shit.
Oh,
okay.
Now I'm going to sit
back down again and be white.
Okay.
I was still waiting for somebody.
Even if it's a feminist,
anything to be up there standing and be like,
why are you applauding right now?
Are you going to do anything about this?
You know what I mean?
And human beings are all selfish shit when you know,
most part you're not.
I Dunno.
Maybe are they,
I know.
Maybe I'm just fucking pessimistic.
I have no idea.
All right,
let's uh,
let's plow ahead here.
Um
Hm.
All right.
American people in their clubs.
Hi,
Bill.
Wanted to ask about you guys across the pond and the way you support your clubs.
All right.
First of all,
we call them teams.
All right?
Just to let you know if you want to blend in,
if you're,
if your government ever goes belly up and you sneak into this country and you
don't want to be found out,
you know that you're an illegal alien.
You say teams,
you don't say clubs and vice versa.
When the dollar collapse,
I'll go over there and be like,
we're like,
oh you support what club you support mate.
Right?
Yeah.
Put another shrimp on the Barbie.
Shagadelic baby.
You have to start quoting awful American movies.
Um,
to me it looks like,
yeah,
you support anyone you fancy anywhere in the u s it seems you support about five
teams in five different sports over in Block II.
We support only like one sport and you keep to it.
Ah,
Jesus Christ.
Can You fucking Pat Yourself?
Lou were fucking loyal over here.
Rarely.
What else you're going to do over there?
The fuck else are you going to do over in Australia?
Don't give me any bullshit cause I've been to your fucking country.
Unless you're in Melbourne.
There ain't shit to do.
Sydney,
Jesus Christ,
Sydney.
It's like Sacramento,
California.
All right,
the whole mill.
Your country is full of the most evil fucking poison his shit ever.
Right.
Okay.
You can't even go there.
That's what ACDC is.
Highway to hell was about,
wasn't it?
Driving from Perth all the way through that fucking shit.
Jesus Christ.
All right,
let's see.
Usually soccer slash football,
um,
is what you support.
But the richer you are,
the,
the sport changes.
Example,
rugby,
tennis is so on,
those are for rich people.
I evidently,
uh,
for the most,
for most people,
you support one team and you live no more than 30 mile radius or at least a two.
Your top league team,
unless you're a glory supporter,
which means a bandwagon or I guess so my question is,
are all Americans glory hunters or is there a way of doing things the novice
can't see?
Go Fuck Yourself.
Yeah.
Dope.
I Dunno what the fuck you talking about.
I support all the Boston teams,
the patriots as far as like,
we have four professional sports and I can't help it that we have more over
here.
See the middle of our country,
we're able to grow enough food to feed the world.
You guys,
the middle of your country,
you have enough poison as shit to murder everybody in the world.
Maybe that's why your teams are only 30 miles of fucking way.
You're trying to just trying to shorten the travel to the stadium so nobody
fucking dies.
Um,
yeah.
So the four major sports over here,
football,
basketball,
baseball and hockey and uh,
I support all the Boston teams.
Those are my favorite teams.
They always have been.
Now since I have a job where I have all this free time,
you know,
I can watch golf majors,
I can watch tennis majors,
I could watch college football,
I could watch college hoop.
I can't watch it and pay attention to at the level that I pay attention to
football and hockey.
You can't even with the four major sports,
like basically somebody who watches and pays attention,
like to baseball and football,
then asked to make a choice with basketball or hockey like this.
Football,
baseball and basketball fans has football,
baseball,
and hockey fans.
And for the most part,
the way the seasons overlap now it's becoming football and basketball,
football and hockey.
Or maybe some of you have just a hardcore like baseball fan.
Um,
you know,
that's basically what it is.
But we definitely have glory support as you call them or um,
bandwagon fans.
There's a lot of bandwagon Yankee fans.
There's a lot of bandwagon,
I'm
like Dallas Cowboy fans when they're good,
you know,
this just certain teams that are like,
I don't know,
they have like national appeal,
but um,
no,
for the most part.
Yeah.
You go and people support the teams
that are in their area.
I don't know what you're seeing are a few here.
Me,
because I talk about all these different sports.
I mean I have to or unless I just want to do like a Boston podcasts,
which kind of limits.
I mean,
this podcast is Boston enough?
I don't want to fucking,
you know,
eliminate all that other,
right.
Do you understand what I'm saying?
I'm not white.
I think we just got a bunch of great sports over here and it's fun to fucking
watch.
But I don't think that people are necessarily any more bandwagon over here.
Well,
I can't say then over there because I don't know what the fuck goes on over
there.
But um,
as usual,
you,
uh,
you're not from the United States and you did what most foreigners do is you in
a very insulting way,
shitting all over,
uh,
America.
You try to act like you're trying to get information as you shit all over us.
Uh,
but the great thing about my job is,
um,
I've been to where you're at and I've smelt your shit and it smells no
differently.
So go fuck yourself.
Um,
anyways,
Aussie rules get day blinky bill.
Um,
no,
I don't think that there's anymore.
I,
like I said,
I guess I don't,
I don't know how many fucking people are glory supporting over there.
Um,
all right,
let's continue.
All right.
Last week you got an email from a fellow Australian fan who asks you to explain
the rules of American football.
In return.
You,
you asked an Aussie to explain our own brand of football.
So here it goes.
Oh,
gee.
Just,
by the way,
I should have just said American football,
you know,
you got two ends of the field.
Both teams defend the end of the field.
That's to their backs.
All right?
The other team gets the fucking ball.
If they run into the end zone or thrown into the end zone,
they get six points followed by an extra point where they kick it through the
uprights for one point.
All right?
If you drive down the field stalls,
you could try to kick the ball through the uprights and you get three points.
If he don't think he can make it,
you punt the ball.
That's it.
That's all I should have said.
Go through the whole first down.
Second down.
All that is too much.
All right.
Australian rules.
That's,
that's chapter two.
All right.
Australian rules football was invented in Melbourne,
Victoria in the 1870s yes.
That long ago.
Well,
why did you think that?
I was going to think that was a long time ago.
Baseball was invented in the 1880s
there's always that insulting,
like fucking like in the United States.
You don't fucking know.
Whoa.
Hey,
change Shevon Geesh.
People were alive,
back,
dead.
Um,
and as a competition between 18 teams from around the nation,
each,
each team plays 22 gains between April and September.
And then the top eight teams on the latter play finals,
football during September,
September and into October.
All right,
so let's play off time.
Winning a game gets to team for premiership points and losing it gets you enough
at AFL is played on a large oval,
about 150 meters from goal to goal.
There really aren't any set dimensions for field of play as the ovals over in
Perth are known to be wider than the fields in Victoria and South Australia.
Well,
back in the day and in the NHL,
hockey rinks were different sizes.
Boston had a smaller rink,
so we more had like grinders,
you know,
physical players.
And then,
uh,
other places,
you know,
if they had a bigger rig,
they went more for fucking speed.
Um,
and the teams used to do shit.
Like,
if the other team was fast,
they wouldn't fucking be,
they'd have the ice be a little more slushy and all that type of shit,
all that type of shit,
you know.
Anyway,
so here we go anyways.
Now to the actual rules,
like in the NFL there is some set point players.
Uh,
but for now let's just break them into defenders midfielders and forwards.
The ball is bounced in the center of the ground at the start of play or after a
goal is score and the opposing Ruckman that was in quotes jumped to try and tap
the ball to their midfield.
Midfield,
there's advantage quite like basketball to dispose of the ball.
A player must either kick it or handball it,
which is essentially holding the ball in one hand and punching it with the
other.
Uh,
player cannot throw the ball but can kick or hand ball in any direction.
The ball must be bounced while a player is running with it,
like in basketball,
but only like every 10 paces if the ball is kicked outside the field of play.
This is actually interesting because I've watched the game and I'm picturing run
these fuckers running around now I kind of get it.
Uh,
if the ball is kicked outside the field of play on the full,
on the full,
what the fuck is that?
A free kick is awarded to the other team.
If it goes out of bounds after bouncing along the ground,
the boundary umpires just throws,
just throws it in.
What the fuck is the fall?
The ball is kicked outside the field of play on the full of free kick.
His award together team.
A free kick.
What to kick it between those posts or to kick it to your other team.
Okay.
I don't fucking know.
If a player catches a ball,
it is called a mark and the umpire referee will blow his whistle and award this
player a few seconds to explore his options and then kick on it.
The player moves past the line.
I've seen all of this shit.
Yeah,
they all clear out.
I,
the play moves past the line where you worry mark the ball,
the umpire calls play on and the player can then be tackled by the opposition.
If he has tackled with the ball and does not get rid of it legally,
it's called holding the ball and the end and the tackle.
He gets a free kick.
What don't you mean?
Then the tackle gets a free kick or wherever it's a tackler.
Falls on the victim's back or makes head high contact.
A free kick is awarded to the player.
He was tackling Jesus Christ.
Dude,
this is way too much information.
This is still going to go.
He's still going here in order to score a player has kicked the ball through his
team center goalposts.
If he does this,
it's worth six points.
However,
if he misses to either side,
the ball goes through
the,
behind the posts.
It's worth just one point.
Oh yeah cause you guys got the two tall ones and then the two smaller ones.
Right.
Usually goals are scored from inside of teams 50 meter arc,
but they don't have to be.
Goals can be kicked by any player on the ground in any way.
You can imagine as long as it comes off the phone,
it is not touched by another player.
Lastly,
a specie
specky come on Kj,
they always had e at the end.
Specky right.
Specky ah,
lastly I went to English to US Ozzie raw specie.
Our Specie is when one player jumps on the ball,
jumps on the shoulders or back of another player to mark the ball there named
appropriately because they are spectacular to watch.
Yeah,
that's a big thing.
Like they don't want to say the whole word,
they just throw he at the Ed Spec.
It was a specky instead of saying spectacular.
Um,
I think anyways,
the only been there a couple times.
It's players are often as high as four meters when they catch the ball,
that's about two a little more than 12 feet in the air.
Thankfully,
head high contact does not apply to SPEC.
He's,
that's about it.
Bill seems like a lot of rules when it all written down,
but I'm sure a season sports pro like yourself could pick it up pretty quickly.
Games.
Um,
are streamed on www.afl.com.
Dot.
EU,
who knows,
maybe AFL could add some excitement to the dry months between hockey,
basketball,
and NFL.
Uh,
if you're looking for a team,
I reckon you'd suit the Western bulldogs.
You love your dogs obviously,
but more than just that,
they also play in the same colors as your patriots and they are based in a
decent working class area.
Just like your beloved Boston.
Uh,
go love yourself by friend.
Thanks for readings and thanks for years of laughs.
Alright,
ps,
blinky bill is a much love Australian cartoon.
Koala.
Oh,
I gotta look that up.
All right,
here comes a creepy one.
Um,
she said rape.
I had a video tape.
All right.
Talk about going from just some bullshit too,
about as heavy a topic as you could have.
All right.
Hey Bill,
I got a little question.
It does sound like a little question dude.
She said rape by a videotape.
All right.
This all sounds crazy.
Last year I had sex with a girl and two days later I was arrested,
charged with rape.
Luckily I filmed it.
I filmed it all as me and a friend had a threesome with tourists.
So it's all good now.
Okay,
wait a minute.
All right.
So if I'm to believe you,
you and your friend had a threesome with this woman.
You filmed it.
Did she know you were filming it?
Maybe you could because you filmed it.
She then got afraid that you're going to show it to people.
So then she did that.
I have no fucking idea.
There's too many.
Maybe you filmed it and she didn't know which would make you a piece of shit.
But then smart because she said it was rape and it wasn't.
That's if I believe you,
that has a lot of variables here.
Uh,
luckily I've filmed it at all as me and a friend had a threesome with her,
so it's all good now.
Do you see,
I have to still doubt this guy because of this thing.
He had a videotape.
The cops watched it and he got off.
I still have to act like she still had a case because it's rape.
You know what I mean?
I have to act like no guy ever gets accused of rape when he didn't rape.
I have to be like,
you know what I mean?
I got to be like those white people at the award shows.
I have to stand up and applaud.
Um,
but the whole thing stresses stress me out so bad that I had to quit my job.
Yeah,
I would think so.
And I've gone to therapy ever since.
Now I always wear a hidden recording device when I'm on a date with a girl.
I got paid $1,000 because all of that happened,
or $1,000 in damages.
The growing other hand didn't suffer a bit.
She was apparently unstable and had reported eight other cases of rape the same
year I was number nine.
Still the police showed up with six men,
two cars in made my room look like a scene from CSI.
Well,
they're just doing their job,
dude.
And as she was unstable,
she didn't have to pay me or any or anything or anyone.
I got paid by the government.
I was risking years behind bars.
Yeah.
And God knows what they would've done to you in there.
I read something in the local paper by another one of her victims that was also
proven innocent,
was being hated on by my country's biggest feminist groups.
Rape is serious,
but this is,
this has to stop.
What are your thoughts on this bill?
Thank you.
Uh,
for your answer and consensually fuck you.
Um,
yeah,
I mean,
I,
I think that's your situation is you're going to get caught up in after years of
it going totally the other way where it was,
where they blamed the victim and said,
well,
what were you wearing?
Um,
you were asking for it.
What did you think was going to happen now?
You know,
which obviously needed to stop that now socially it's gone from where they
blamed the victim to me back in the day.
They'd be like,
well,
you were drinking.
What did you think was gonna Happen?
Um,
they've gone all the way to the other side now where it's just like if she said
she was raped,
she was raped.
So,
which isn't a bad,
what makes it a bad fucking thing is the fact that they put the accused name in
the picture and everything
in the fucking paper before anything has been proven.
I am an advocate of you.
Protect both people until something has been proven,
either innocence or guilt.
All right?
And if it's innocent,
you let that person get back on with their life because you cannot shake that.
It's over the second year accused of that shit.
It's fucking over.
You know,
it's,
it's complete.
It's over.
You are branded that for the rest of your fucking life.
And when you have somebody out there,
if they're fucking unstable and they're doing this for whatever fucking reason,
I mean,
God knows what horrible thing happened to this person that they're doing this.
Um,
or maybe they were born unstable.
I have no fucking idea.
But
you know,
the fact that you know,
you get 1000 bucks,
you're in therapy,
you gotta quit your fucking job and all that.
Uh,
I mean,
uh,
look,
who's kidding?
Who Dude?
All right.
You had a fucking threesome.
Alright.
You videotape and the fucking thing,
I mean,
I don't know that you had,
ah,
I can't say don't wear a fucking recording device.
I totally understand why you would,
I totally get that.
But I would just say,
why don't you,
you know,
try to date somebody a little more stable.
I mean,
you go on dates versus,
you know,
hooking up with some crazy person who's having a threesome and letting your film
the fucking thing.
I mean right there,
dude,
if you fucking like,
if you hook up with somebody,
you don't fucking know him from Adam and they're going to have a fucking
threesome and they're going to let you film the fucking thing.
I mean right there,
I mean the amount of red flags that should be flying in your face,
you shouldn't even be seeing the person anymore.
Here I am blaming you again.
You're probably a young guy.
You never had the,
so you learned your fucking lesson here.
Um,
I dunno dude.
Like if,
if if secretly wearing a recording device,
you know,
makes you feel more comfortable,
I then,
I,
I don't have a problem with it.
I mean do,
do you,
I don't know if you've ever heard like what happens to rape is and in,
in jail,
uh,
you know,
they like hunted down if fucking gang raped and all of that type of shit just
fucking horrific.
What could have happened to you?
Just cause she said that that happened and um,
those feminist groups that are doing that shit.
I mean Dave basically exposing themselves for what they truly are is they're
sexist.
They're totally fucking sexist to any woman says a guy does anything.
They just totally have their fucking,
they didn't give a shit.
I made this was this person even in that year said that,
you know,
someone raped and didn't raped her and didn't,
I mean right there they did a little bit of fucking where they just immediately
back them.
Let me guess.
Did they apologize to you at all?
You know,
I'm sure they didn't.
Did they is as big as a fucking surge that they did online or wherever they were
coming at you when they apologized,
which should have been even bigger.
Did they?
I'm sure they didn't.
You know,
cause there's sexist.
They are.
They don't give a shit.
They sit there and they pat themselves on the back like did these socially
advanced fucking people and they aren't.
They're the exact fucking thing that they're fighting the exact moron,
sexist guy that thinks a woman should just be there to suck his dick and make
them a sandwich.
They had the female version of that are the female fucking virgin that generally
fucking speaking and I can speak in generalities considering how they treated
you.
Um,
all right,
there we go.
Telling guitarist he's bad.
Hey Billy Bonzo bill,
I love you and I need you to help.
All right.
I am a 16 year old guy from Egypt.
That's so fucking cool.
And you listen to this podcast.
That's awesome.
Yes,
you have fans in Egypt.
Anyway,
I have been playing guitar for two years now and I started a band with some
friends.
That's awesome.
A drummer,
a bass player,
and an another guitar player.
Here's the problem.
We're having trouble with the guitar player.
He is flashy.
He is a flashy fuck with no talent.
He never practiced enough as very bad quality guitar and amp learn solos only.
It doesn't even play them correctly.
And he wants me to play the rhythm section while he shifts the lead parts.
I don't have a problem and playing rhythm,
but only if he can play well to put his failure into perspective.
He's been playing guitar for over six years and most people tell me I'm way
better than him.
Not trying to be cocky or anything,
just shitting on him more and more,
uh,
where I live.
Finding another guitarist who can actually play is very difficult.
So it's hard to let them go while we have a gig coming in October.
So should we let them go and find another guy?
And if so,
can we tell him that he is out?
Okay.
No,
Jesus Christ.
So this,
there's a lot of variables in this one.
All right.
So if I am to believe that this guy stinks as much as you do and not that this
is some
cliched in band fighting where you're playing rhythm and he's playing leads.
So all the chicks wanna Bang him afterwards and you're standing there like,
what about me,
y'all remi,
everyone wants to fuck Angus.
Nobody wants to fuck Malcolm over here.
You know,
um,
as long as it isn't,
that just guy truly does suck.
And if you're actually better than him,
then um,
okay,
why don't you turn yourselves into a power?
Okay.
You know,
and then all you got to do is have your bass player and your drummer.
We'll give them more space for when you're playing the lead.
Um,
it would make you a better guitar is to,
especially if there's some space within those leads and then you could hit a
couple of fucking the rhythm chords,
then go put it in and out of the fucking and make you a better guitars.
I mean,
I can tell you right now,
Dan,
if you think this guy's a flashy fuck with no talent and he's not practicing and
he's been playing three times,
as long as you and you feel you're better,
I don't see you guys ever coming to a point where you're going to be happy with
what the fuck he's doing.
Um,
my only question is though,
you do need some showmanship and the band,
I would think because sometimes somebody can be better than somebody else,
but they stand there and they look like a fucking toad waiting for a flight to
come by.
And then at that point you literally have to be a musician to understand how
what they're doing.
Cause there is,
you know,
you also have to entertain people.
So,
uh,
always flashy shit though.
That could get you some gigs.
You know what I mean?
In the beginning,
who knows?
I don't know.
Are you,
you'd have to assess all of that.
But if you,
the drummer and the Bass player all on the same page and you just think this
guy's a flush,
you fuck who's,
who's not bringing anything to the band,
then uh,
then yeah,
I bounced the guy maybe after you gig in October,
if there's not enough time to find somebody,
know,
maybe play one more fucking Gig and they get rid of them.
Uh,
but if,
if he's actually,
yeah,
there's been a lot of flashy guys that couldn't quite fucking play,
but they were fun to watch.
And the bands made it.
So I don't know that,
that,
that part of it is going to have to be up to you.
But,
uh,
I think there's opportunity there for you to become an even better guitars if
you want to try to hold down his parts for a while until you find somebody else
and then you know what,
you only have to split the gig money three ways instead of four.
Okay.
All I would say is if you're going to start playing leads,
then uh,
I would still a little bit of that guy's moves in his fashion sense.
You know what I mean?
You got to do a couple of things.
You can't be standing back dead fucking,
I don't know.
Like I said,
like that towed on a lily pad.
All right.
A Canadian politician wants to stunt population growth.
A Broccoli bill just saw this article about Elizabeth May,
the leader of,
of our Green party,
the number for a political party in Canada who supports reducing the world's
population a figure.
It's up your alley.
That's amazing.
Uh,
here's the link to her party platform.
But since you suck at reading,
here are a few of the main points of what she wants to do.
That's hilarious.
I was even struggling reading that sentence.
Uh,
one,
integrate goals for reduced fertility in the overall effort to eliminate
poverty.
Uh,
what does that mean?
Yeah,
she wants to sterilize poor people.
Okay.
Uh,
this does not sound green.
This sounds like brown shirt.
Uh,
realize that failure to stabilize and reduce human population will result in the
inevitable reduction of human population by means of high death rates as the
Earth's human carrying capacity is not only exceeded but reduced by the
consumption of resources and the destruction of biological capitol resulting in
poverty,
starvation,
disease,
great human suffering and possibly social disruption apps.
A fucking Luli check all of those off.
Uh,
integrate goals for improved healthcare and spreading knowledge of birth control
methods and efforts than increase the availability of the ability of birth
control equipment and supplies into the overall efforts to eliminate poverty for
recognize that the high level of per capita resource consumption and developed
countries makes the impact of their population much more serious.
Stoked to see you in Toronto for a couple of weeks.
Just uh,
just for last and thanks for the podcast.
You Dope.
Um,
well it's freaking is stupid.
You're going to fucking see me next week unless this is leftover from awhile
ago.
You actually get to see me this week,
so it's not a couple of weeks.
Um,
what I think needs to be done is I think that there just needs to be from top to
bottom information on what the human population is doing to the oceans,
to the air,
to the trees,
to all of that type of shit.
And at this point is not,
this is not even tree hugger shit.
This is just literally fact.
Um,
that just needs to be way less fucking people.
And if you just like,
I was going to say prognosticated is that actually worried if you just
projected,
if you just showed what the fuck we're headed towards and you scared the fuck
out of people and you somehow,
this is why it's not going to work.
You've got to get everybody on the same page and you've got to get people to
not,
uh,
act selfishly.
It's like if there's a fucking plane crash right into the fucking mountains and
the survivors are sitting there and they pulled together all the resources they
have and they're all on the same team,
no matter what,
there's always going to be that person who's out for themselves.
Okay.
And that's just in a group of fucking 20 people.
So if you just factor that in into 7 billion people,
the amount of people that are out there for themselves,
um,
I don't think that it works and I think that we are,
uh,
we are doomed to.
So that second paragraph with is,
uh,
you know,
resulting in poverty,
starvation,
disease,
great human suffering and possible social disruption.
I think that that's going to happen.
I think the upper 1% realizes that and I think they're insulating themselves.
Um,
from that inevitability by pooling the resources for themselves,
turning places into police states,
getting rid of rights and living in gated communities.
They are all set.
All right.
They are all set for all of that shit that happened.
Um,
and that's just my paranoid fucking 2 cents.
anyways,
so that's a podcast here for this week.
Um,
I'll send you that,
that video of the porpoises swimming through the ocean while there's still
there.
And,
uh,
what else?
I think that's it.
I got an Ohio,
so I got to run a dates this week,
man.
If you're in Texas.
All right,
I'm going to be in Austin for two shows tonight.
I'm going to be in San Antonio.
I'm going to be in Dallas,
I'm going to be in Houston.
Um,
is that it?
I think that that is it.
No El Paso on this run.
No college station,
no Corpus Christi.
None of that shit.
So,
you know,
you might have to drive a little bit,
but I'm driving all over the Aha to Texas and I'm,
and on Sunday I'm going to be at the just for laughs in Toronto.
I got a whole new hour is shit.
I am rested up sort of from,
uh,
my,
my week out there and then tuck it.
And,
um,
I'm not really rusted up.
I smoked a fucking cigar every day.
I smoked two on one day and I am fucking spent.
But that'll give me fuel for my standup act.
So anyways,
uh,
I think that's it.
That's the podcasts.
Go fuck yourselves.
I will tell.
I'll check on Thursday.
See you.